Oh yeah, that's a mustache,
which could only mean one thing!
Good morning Hank, it's
Monday! It's Pizzamas!
I don't really know how to change up
the vibe from our community
lowers the price of
life-saving tuberculosis tests
to Pizzamas, where we make
videos back and forth every
day like it was 2007 all over
again while celebrating the
seven minutes in 2008 when I
had a mustache, but we're doing it!
But of course
Pizzamas isn't just about my
occasional mustache and
constant love for pizza
It'salso about e-commerce!
And inside of this box is all of
this year's Pizzamas magic,
which I have not seen yet.
So every year all of our proceeds
go to charity because,
you know, of course we can't live
with ourselves profiting from Pizzamas.
But this year the
money raised is going to be
focused around tuberculosis.
We've done a great job of
lowering the cost of
diagnostics and treatments,
but now we need to get those
diagnostics and treatments to more people
So that's what we're
raising money for this year
We're gonna start with
the t-shirts
(laughs)
I love it so much!
So this is a Pizza John collab with Drawfee
and I love it!
Look at that. It's so great.
Okay, what's next?
I mean, I just absolutely love
this. I love my face in it.
Look at my enthusiasm for pizza.
It's so real!
(laughing)
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes!
I just love the t-shirts so much every year.
How, how did this happen?
How did Pizzamas occur?
What, what is my life?
It's my dream, Hank.
It's my dream
to one day be not just a postage stamp,
but a Pizza John postage stamp
Alright, I only have a couple more
shirts to share with you this year.
Look at this one!
Ugh! Magnificent!
Look at me!
Oh, I should add that
all of these shirts and
indeed all of the Pizzamas stuff is
only available during Pizzamas
You can only get it for the next two weeks
and then it disappears forever.
Pizzamas.com or our new
Pizzamas app on your local app store
Alright, this is the last...
(laughs)
It's the last shirt of the year and...
Look at me up in the corner as a baby
but I still got a mustache!
(laughs)
Oh boy
I, uh, I don't... know what to say
about this development
except to say that it's...
it's a major work of art.
But of course Hank, it doesn't,
and can't, end with t-shirts
Oh no. No, no, no.
It has to include:
a phenomenal
Pizza John holiday sweater!
Oh yeah, I mean look at this.
This is just excellent.
You may remember that a few years ago
we made this Pizza John
blanket which is super
comfortable and I love it so much
But this one is also super comfortable
and I think I love it even more.
You have to be shitting me
It's Cheez-A-John, a john that
grows its own hair
in the form of plants
This one you can
only buy in the United States
because it has seeds!
(laughs)
Alright, this is one I'm really excited about:
It's Pizza John's hot sauce
Now, I'm not legally allowed to sell
the hot sauce that I make with my mom
because it's not made in a
commercial kitchen,
but this tastes pretty much like it.
This is also only available in the United States
because it's like technically food or whatever
but highly recommended!
Oh, we've got a mug printed in Missoula that
changes color when you pour hot liquid into it
I'm not telling you what color it chan-
I'm not gonna ruin the surprise!
This is a Pizza John bath bomb.
Fortunately, it does not smell like pizza, but
do you know what it does smell like?
Like, so much like?
Dr. Pepper
Live the dream,
turn your bath into Dr. Pepper, Pizzamas.com!
We've also got this badass oven mitt.
You have to be kidding me, this
cannot be real.
It's a real neon sign!
That's right, Hank!
It's a fully functioning Pizza John's neon sign.
We've also got lots of different stickers
and bumper stickers this year
from the charming and funny
To the exceptionally creepy.
There's also so much other
Pizzamas stuff this year.
A pizza slicer, earrings,
there's a stereogram poster,
one of those posters where
when you unfocus your eyes a
new image appears.
You'll never guess what the image is.
Actually, you will guess
on the first try.
Hank, Nerdfighteria,
what a joy it has been
to go through my eras with you.
Hank, I'll see you tomorrow for more Pizzamas!
and potentially,
for your first ever mustache?
Like, I think we're all curious
which way it's gonna go
We know something's going to happen
with the facial hair tomorrow,
but everybody is waiting with
bated breath to find out exactly what.